so there's a new project called bubbles
and it's aiming to create urban parks
inside a giant bubble this really
reminds me I don't know if you guys
played SimCity back in the day but when
you got into the future in SimCity the
deep future like 2050 everything sort of
looked like this we've got a couple more
images of these things and this is
through or project which is designed as
a response to rising pollution affecting
cities in Asia and it's got a way that
it's going to filter air flowing inside
parts while controlling temperature and
humidity uh you know look this sort of
seems like this all looks like the
future to me it looks a little bit like
Elysium you know this in this future
where you know the ozone layer has been
depleted and we gotta watch out for the
Sun and our air is no good and all that
stuff are we gonna be bubble people is
it is everyone gonna be a bubble boy
like in Seinfeld gonna be rolling around
like our personal bubble or Pauly Shore
and bio dome yeah well so this is bio
dome this is basically it's being under
your cake dome yeah I'm in it all came
around I never want to leave it um is
this the future really I mean we can't
stop climate change right so why don't
we just manage it and live in bubble see
as long as only the wealthy can use it
I'm fine with it because right now this
is essentially like putting a roof over
the open air shelter that is the the
public park mmm and I just think this is
gonna make homeless people too
comfortable I think that's the problem
that's the thing is like I mean yeah
you're gonna know I think we need to
like yes make parks more livable and I
think instead of just putting a dome
over them we need to fix the pollution
problem Rises putting a very
strange-looking soap and water band-aid
over a much larger wound right so it
seems to me that what they're doing here
is there sort of giving up on the idea
that we can reverse climate change or
fix it which that's what scientists are
saying now we can't go back so we may as
well do these types of things and be
growing our agriculture in these domes
and all that is it too late well thank
you I we need Oprah in order to fix
climate change um no I actually I think
don't we need don't people need
antibodies or they need to be out in
nature no you watch goes right so bubble
people will never if it were bubble wrap
that would haha that would be fun
terrible for the birds we're like oh
look at all those trees funk and they're
just like face first on this strange
bubble although they have to get in the
bubble like they do I've seen birds at
the airport yeah right in there every
now and again so this is sort of like
the dome from the simpsons movie so we
want to keep out the idiot birds and
only breed very smart birds yeah we we
put the dome over the top and only the
ones who are wise enough to get in i
will put the head shots of birds that
don't like people the callback queen
right now ladies night all together yeah
is this going to lead us to other
planets you think that's going to be the
thing maybe we won't get it quite right
here we'll do it here for a little bit
but that's going to be the trick of how
we end up living on Mars or on pandora
from Avatar some yeah pretty much we're
gonna end up in domes on other planets
yes you're on board I believe domes on
other plan i think domes on other
planets and i'm only behind this bubble
thing if the way you make it is you take
a huge one of those like big bubble
wands that like surprises children and
someone just like you put it like the
Statue of Liberty's hand from
ghostbusters 2 it just kind of haha yeah
we should give Harold Ramis a little
shout out but you know he passed away
this week one of the great comedy
legends where do you think the first
dome is gonna pop up I'm thinking this
has to be like a Brooklyn like hipsters
are gonna want to live in a dome mm-hmm
and then it'll become cool for a little
while and then everyone want out of it I
think South by Southwest ya gotta be
battle me via their first dome will
definitely day music festival and then
go from there you have a dome I think
yeah yeah South by Southwest and they'll
take the homeless people who are in the
park and turn them into mobile hotspots
outside of the park Oh writer and then
that'll we're gonna work out just fine
for everyone